Ừ cảm ơn bạn đến với kênh tin học Đỗ Bảo
Nam blog video ngày hôm nay Đỗ Bảo Nam
blog sẽ chia sẻ với bạn cách nhập key
Office bản quyền cho nhiều máy tính
nếu như bạn đã có cây Office 365 bản
quyền hoặc Microsoft 360 bản quyền thi
bạn hoàn toàn có thể cài đặt cho nhiều
máy tính khác nhau
Ví dụ ở trên máy tính này của mình hiện
tại chưa được cài Word Excel hay là
PowerPoint Vân Vân bây giờ mình sẽ cài
Office hay nói cách khác các phần mềm
Word Excel Powerpoint vào máy tính này
và nhập key bản quyền cho nó các bước
bạn thực hiện như sau
bước thứ nhất bạn có thể vào Microsoft
Store để tải ứng dụng Office
bạn nhập từ khóa làm mai còn sốt
ở
đây bạn tìm đến là mai có sốt 365
bạn nhấp vào kết quả này
tiếp theo
bạn nhấn và Mods ở phía bên tay trái để
vào quản lý cái tài khoản
khi đó bạn sẽ được điều hướng đến một
trình duyệt web để bạn đăng nhập tài
khoản Microsoft
ở đây ví dụ mình sinh nhập tài khoản và
bạn nhấp là tiếp theo
các bạn Nhập khẩu của bạn vào
sau khi bản đã đăng nhập tài khoản thì
mai còn Shop sẽ điều hướng đến trang tài
khoản và cho mày bạn có thể quản lý được
rất nhiều thông tin của tài khoản
Microsoft
ngoài cách vào quản lý tài khoản thông
qua Microsoft Store Ừ thì bạn khỏe vào
trực tiếp trên trang web bằng cách gõ
địa chỉ là bạn ơi cao chém microsoft.com
họ bạn nhấp vào quản lý Microsoft 365
gạch
thì bạn cũng được trang web tương tự như
ở phía bên này mình đăng nhập trên thì
duyệt Chrome
sau khi bạn đang vào trang quản lý tài
khoản mai con shop thì bạn hãy chuyển
sang Bước 2 cài đặt ứng dụng Office cho
máy tính
trong trường học bạn vào thông qua micro
store thì giao diện của bạn sẽ như thế
này thì bạn chỉ cần nhấp vào đây Nhấn
vào cái dòng cài đặt các ứng dụng Office
cao cấp bao gồm Word Excel PowerPoint và
một số ứng dụng khác bạn nhấp vào đây
Ừ
nhưng mà cái mũi tên này
ở đây Bạn phải chọn ngôn ngữ tiếng Việt
hoặc tiếng Anh hoặc là một hôm bữa khác
video đây mình sẽ vẫn chọn là tiếng Anh
và bạn có thể chọn phiên bản với dùng
khi màn võ phim mặc định hoặc ở đây mình
có thể cho phiên bản là 64 bit
mà bạn nhấp vào cài đặt
trong trường hợp bạn vào trực tiếp thì ở
trên cái trang quản lý tài khoản này bạn
cài đặt hoàn toàn tương tự ở đây Bạn
phải nhấp vào cái chữ đó đặt cài đặt các
ứng dụng Office ở trên menu như thế này
thì ngơi cho nó bạn cũng được điều hướng
đến một cửa sổ để bạn phải chọn ngôn ngữ
và chọn phiên bản đấy các video đây mình
sẽ chọn cái ngôn ngữ tiếng Anh
vẫn chọn là Office Center mít
và mình Ừ để bắt đầu Tải và cài đặt phần
mềm
ở đây bạn nhìn thấy Office của mình đang
được tải về
như vậy bộ cài đặt Office của mình đã
tải về
Bây giờ bạn có thể nhấp vào cái mục gào
phim này để bắt đầu cài đặt ứng dụng
Office Word Excel PowerPoint vân vân
trong trường hợp trình duyệt bạn sử dụng
là trình duyệt Google Chrome thì khi tải
về
bạn sẽ thấy cái ứng dụng Office ở phía
dưới này
thì bạn cũng chỉ cần nhất vào cái bộ ca
này để bắt đầu cài đặt các ứng dụng
Office
ví dụ bây giờ mình sẽ Nhấn và ứng dụng
này sau khi hoạt bộ cài phải xong Bây
giờ mình sẽ nhấn vào đây
Ừ
như vậy ứng dụng Office giá bắt đầu cài
đặt thì bạn chỉ cần nhấp vào nút để cho
phép ứng dụng cài vào máy tính
mà bạn đợi trong ít phút để ứng dụng cài
vào máy tính
như vậy quá trình cài đặt đã được bắt
đầu và bạn chỉ cần đợi để các phần mềm
trong bộ Office sẽ được cài vào máy tính
của bạn
như vậy mình đã cài xong bộ phần mềm
Office Bây giờ bạn có thể Click vào
close để đóng cái cửa sổ cài đặt
à Mà bạn chỉ cần kích vào nút start thì
ngay lập tức bạn đã thấy các ứng dụng
Office đã được cài đặt vào máy tính bạn
có thể kéo thả ra ngoài desktop để sử
dụng cho tiện việc đây mình sẽ kéo thả
ba cái phần mềm thường xuyên sử dụng đó
là Word Excel và PowerPoint
ạ Bây giờ mình sẽ mở thử
Ừ
thì mang đi hết đi phiên bản của mình
đang làm ai có shop 365
A
và khi mà bạn mới mở thì phần mềm có một
số thông báo bạn có thể ta đi
bao nhiêu vậy video của mình kết thúc
tại đây nếu bạn có những câu hỏi cần
được hỗ trợ Dạo này không nên chứa kiểu
thế giới video này Cảm ơn bạn đã theo
dõi video Xin chào và hẹn gặp lại bạn ở
các clip tiếp theo